David, you've talked before about how the modern
Republican Party under Trump is basically just
about owning the Libs. And Meems, it's no
longer about policy. Does it matter if they
keep on winning? I mean, listen, they didn't.
Win, they lost in twenty eighteen and they lost
in twenty twenty, so it's not clear that they're
continuing to win. But I think the important
question is, when you have so many Republicans
who don't really know anything about policy
and you have so many Republicans that no
matter what, aren't voting for Democrats,
policy really doesn't matter very much
when you put out policy and then you fail
and then your constituents don't hold you
accountable anyway. Why bother putting out
policy at all? And there are some Republicans
who are actually taking this and running with
it. Madison Cawthorn, this new Trumpy, an elected
Republican member of the House of Representatives,
one of his aides, I think it was that someone
in his circle said, we're not running a policy
office. We're running a communications office,
which is social media and interviews and
confrontations that that are visually compelling
in this type of thing. These are their voters.
Right. And if they don't need to put out policy
and risk failing to achieve it and the voters
are more interested in ways to own the Libs and
Meems, in this type of thing, then they're going
to be that's what they're going to get. And in
fact, it's happening. Republican voters have
been fed a constant stream of propaganda for about
six years now. Right. It's twenty twenty one. You
go back to twenty fifteen. When Trump started
running and they've rewarded this behavior,
the guy who said without any details, I'm going to
get rid of Obamacare and do something beautiful.
I'm going to build a wall across the entire
border. I'm going to fix trade. Except he ended
up, you know, replacing NAFTA with the I don't
even remember what it's called now, but it was
more or less the exact same thing. They're fed
the propaganda and they reward the candidates
that feed it to them. They're represented by the
political equivalent of Internet trolls and they
love it. And when your priority is messing with
the other side, making liberals feel bad or look
bad or whatever, it becomes a feedback loop.
The propaganda of Fox News and of Republicans
gives an alternate reality to the Republican voter
so that the Republican voter no longer cares about
policy. And they use the propaganda to say, well,
I can't vote for Biden because he's a communist
socialist. I can't vote for Hillary because she
has Parkinson's or whatever the case may be,
and then they don't. And then it makes it so
Republicans continue to say, why run on policy?
I'll run on Meems. And this goes for elected
officials. This goes for Fox News, Newsmax. And
that's how they push this stuff. And generally
speaking, it works. Now, you can make the case,
well, does it work? They lost the house
in twenty eighteen. They lost the Senate
in twenty twenty. They lost the White House in
twenty twenty. I just have a hard time believing
that policy would have done better for them
because their voters have been so propagandized
to. And that's the question I'll leave to you.
Is there an advantage? I know that some of the
traditional Republicans, you get back with a
focus on policy, assuming it's the right policy,
but do they lose all of these trumpeter's who
never paid attention to politics to begin with
and just showed up for the Mexican rapists type
comments? Is it really a net benefit to go back to
policy for the Republican Party? Let me know what
you think. Bonus show today, this is the last show
and bonus show before our break, we are off next
week. The show's not canceled. Everything's fine.
We're just taking a week off to regenerate
some energy. And then we'll be back to we got.